- First, I want
(audience claps)
to talk about a beauty influencer
with a special talent for storytelling.
Literally, I've heard so many
people tell me about her.
She's a makeup artist turned
true crime phenomenon.
Each week, Bailey showcases
the latest in makeup
while dishing the juiciest details
of notorious crime cases,
which is so hilarious.
And I would have never put those together.
Her viral YouTube series,
"Murder, Mystery, and Makeup"
has more than 400 million views.
Let's get her on the line right now.
What's up Bailey?
Hi Kelly.
(audience claps and cheers)
- Hi.
I mean, how did you come up with it?
- I don't know.
I mean, like, I've always been fascinated
with true crime and makeup.
When I was a kid, my mom
was a 9-1-1 dispatcher,
and she used to take me to work with her,
and I would like listen
in to the phone calls,
which we laugh about it
now, but looking back,
it probably wasn't the best idea
for her to take me
(Kelly and audience laugh)
to work, you know (laughs)?
And then like, so I've just been obsessed
with true crime for as
long as I can remember.
And then as far as makeup goes,
I mean I wasn't allowed
to wear makeup growing up
until about in my '20s is
when I started to dabble,
and I got a job at Sephora,
and then I started my YouTube channel,
and it just, I mean, it
just, I'm here (laughs).
It's a lot.
(audience laughs)
- No, it's taken over.
Well, I know several people
that think you're hilarious by the way.
They're like, "Oh my God, she's hilarious
while telling me a story."
So what surprised you the most
like researching all these stories?
- I think a lot, well, I
used to be a big believer
that some people were just born evil,
like most people were just born evil.
But after doing these stories for so long,
I realized that it all comes down to like
how they were raised and
also their upbringing,
their relationship with their parents,
and then head trauma is like
a common thread in a lot of,
some of the worst killers.
And I mean, it's just bizarre.
So I think a lot of the
times we personally think
like these monsters are monsters,
and really they're not.
They're just like the normal
people who live next door
who just had a really rough life (laughs).
Which isn't an excuse.
- Well that
is terrifying news.
That is like.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I know, I know, I don't.
- I mean, we have a whole
campaign on here called,
you know, good neighbor,
and I'm now terrified
officially of my neighbors
who might not be good, who
might've, I don't know,
fell off the horse
- Sorry.
- and bumped their head
and might kill me now.
That's why I can't, okay,
I can't get into true crime a lot,
because I was, I was so invested,
and I watched every "Dateline"
thing, I got so into it.
And then I started become
physically terrified,
didn't sleep, 'cause I was so terrified.
I was like, so they
probably know that one guy,
he got to the third floor,
so they could get up here.
I mean, I sit here and
like play out scenarios.
So I got so crazy, but I think
it's hilarious what you do.
I think it's so innovative too.
Nobody's else is doing it.
So thank you Bailey for joining us.
- Thank you so much
for having me.
(audience cheers and claps)
- Absolutely.
And you look beautiful,
so well done on your makeup (laughs).